hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ihr seht es bereits im Titel
eingeblendet denn meine Mission ist es
heute den vollgeist Weltrekord zu
brechen in den letzten Monaten habe ich
zahlreiche Videos auf meiner tiktok for
you page angezeigt bekommen wo Leute
Weltrekorde in Folge als aufgestellt
haben und das alles hat dazu geführt
dass
ich die Berufung hatte das auch mal zu
probieren
ich muss das Los geht's meine Damen und
Herren wir versuchen ein Weltrekord
aufzustellen das hier geht runter das
heißt jetzt geht das in der Mitte hoch
perfekt wir sind als erstes durch okay
wir gehen direkt zu diesem hierhin in
einem durchlaufen perfekt okay wir sind
drüber das ist eine Möglichkeit den
Weltrekord zu brechen wir gehen hier hin
wir gehen hier hin perfekt okay erster
Platz ist auf jeden Fall drin dass sie
öffnet sich jetzt für uns oh mein Gott
es ist der Berufung wir haben schon
wieder geschafft komm Junge komm komm
komm komm Schlaf du ja komm erster Platz
ist meiner 5 Sekunden später
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jeder kleine fußstapfer hat mal bei
einem Pferd angefangen
los geht's zwei Runden müssen wir
schaffen ich habe das noch nie gespielt
aber vielleicht ist gerade das die gute
Sache für mich komm okay wir sind sehr
gut mit dabei wir sind sehr gut mit
dabei das erinnert mich gerade so ein
bisschen an Mario Kart an diese Strecke
wo man auch so die ganze Zeit diese
diese schnell diese highspeed-strecke wo
man wenn man über diese Dinge rüber
fährt dass man die ganze Zeit Münzen
bekommt aber gut wir sind auf jeden Fall
extrem gut dabei oh mein Gott das haben
wir auch geschafft wir schaffen es wir
schaffen es wir schaffen sie gehen hier
links rum da kriegen wir noch einen
kleinen Bus zack zack zack hier
rumlaufen das geht wurde schnell ich bin
richtig gut mit dabei zack hierdurch
wieder schneller und weiter kommen
raftig komm Junge komm hier an der Seite
lang es regnet nicht spenden kann aber
schnell weiter geht oh
habe ich gesehen jetzt laufen lauf lauf
laufen schnell wir müssen hier den Bus
kriegen
okay okay es ist doch alles drin es ist
alles drin lass dich davon nicht
berühren es ist alles drin Luca es ist
doch alles drin schnell hierdurch
warum ich bin so verloren ich bin so
verloren das wird auf keinen Weltrekord
aber die nächste Strecke die nächste
Strecke werden
komm Junge komm komm komm komm das ist
sehr gut das ist sehr gut das ist sehr
gut hier vorne dem Ding ausweichen
perfekt jetzt hier durch oh verdammt
lauf lauf lauf lauf lauf lauf lauf lauf
lauf wir müssen es einfach nur irgendwie
schaffen dass wir den nächsten kriegen
komm junge
komm es sind schon 26 durchkommen
kleiner laufen bisschen schneller ja
[Applaus]
nächste Strecke machen mit Safe
Weltrekord nächste Strecke ist der
Wirbel Freunde wir müssen einfach auf
diesen Band bleiben wir dürfen nicht
runterfahren
Lauf okay nichts passiert oh okay okay
einfach rüber springen es ist wieder
nichts passiert okay zack zack sehr gut
sehr gut hier lang hier lang hier lang
nichts passiert nichts passiert gibt sie
denn irgendwo ein Ziel oder geht das
hier die ganze Zeit weiter was wenn ich
stehen bleibe okay es geht automatisch
weiter das heißt wir laufen am besten
oh mein Gott ey ich habe so ein Glück oh
jetzt hier weiter oh mein Gott ey sind
schon acht ausgeschieden wir könnten es
wirklich ins Finale schaffen wir könnten
es wirklich ins Finale schaffen oh mein
Gott oh mein Gott oh mein Gott
ich sag euch ich hole den win obwohl ich
diese ganzen Strecken nicht kenne hier
darf man nicht runterfallen also man
soll den Schleim unten nicht berühren
und das ist so eine Wippe das heißt wir
gehen einfach mal in die Mitte oh mein
Gott
okay das ist natürlich ein bisschen
kontraproduktiv wenn jetzt hier die
ganze Zeit Blaubeeren und Erdbeeren und
keine Ahnung was gescheitert wird aber
ich glaube es kommt nur von der Seite
zwei Leute sind schon ausgeschieden sind
Idioten also sorry so schwer ist das
jetzt auch nicht hier vorne drauf zu
bleiben oh mein Gott
eine Beere auch oh mein Gott
was sind das denn für Idioten
bisher hat das jetzt noch nicht so ganz
geklappt mit den Weltrekorden aber Rom
wird auch nicht in einer Nacht der baut
und daher probieren wir es einfach noch
mal los geht's das ist auf jeden Fall
eine Strecke die ich kenne es können
sich 42 Leute qualifizieren was halt
echt nicht fair ist es dazu bei diesen
ganzen Folge als Weltrekord Videos die
Leute halt einfach in erster Reihe
stehen ich verstehe nicht kann man das
irgendwie beeinflussen dass ich
irgendwie als erster starte oder so weil
warum ich ich stand von hinten das ist
nicht fertig kann hier kein Weltrekord
aufstellen ich glaube bisher eine
perfekte Runde und die Leute sind alle
vor mir oh mein Gott
okay shift och mann Alter
starte allerdings geht es jetzt hier
vorne weiter mit diesem Ding da spring
ich natürlich gekommen durch und jetzt
müssen wir einfach durch die Mitte gehen
wir müssen es schaffen durch die Mitte
durchzulaufen
ich töte deine Arsch einfach hier an der
Seite lang
zack okay in der Ruhe liegt die Kraft
einfach rüber springen sag hier war das
Ding und jetzt haben wir den perfekten
weg und kann quasi niemand mehr
aufhalten zack okay perfekt das schaffen
wir Weltrekord haben wir jetzt nicht
ganz gebrochen aber in der nächsten
Runde
Runde Nummer zwei meine Damen und Herren
wir müssen hier wieder zweimal im
Kreislauf laufen auf der Strecke die ich
eh schon gespielt habe oh mein Gott
hatte das mit der Weltrekord ich sag's
euch das wieder Weltrekord oh mein Gott
oh mein Gott ey dass sie der Weltrekord
ich sag's euch Teil das umgeschnitten
nein lass
egal ich werde auf jeden Fall
okay okay hier lang hier lang hier lang
hier lang hier weiter
nicht dadurch aufpassen
okay weiter geht's weiter geht's weiter
geht's weiter geht's Luca konzentriere
Dich konzentriere Dich konzentriere dich
[Musik]
ich bin erster ich bin's weiter nach
einer
oh mein Gott
das war nicht gut das war nicht gut es
wird aber
komm aber ich werde auf jeden Fall noch
den ersten Platz holen
[Musik]
das ist so gut das ist so gut
ist gerade so stark
nein nein
er soll noch eine kleine zerstören
es soll nicht sein
es soll einfach nicht sein
irgendwer will nicht dass ich irgendwas
erreiche
[Musik]